>>> GOOD EVENING.
FACEBOOK LIKES TO SAY IT WAS
BUILT TO BRING PEOPLE TOGETHER.
IT LITERALLY USES THOSE WORDS IN
PROMOTIONAL MATERIAL.
WELL, TODAY, IT DID BRING PEOPLE
TOGETHER.
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN A LONG
TIME, DEMOCRATIC AND REPUBLICAN
MEMBERS OF A SENATE COMMERCE
SUBCOMMITTEE WERE TOGETHER,
UNITED IN THEIR PRAISE OF
WHISTLE-BLOWER FRANCES HAUGEN.
NOW, AS YOU KNOW, SHE IS THE
FORMER-FACEBOOK PRODUCT MANAGER
WHO LEAKED TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
PAGES OF INTERNAL DOCUMENTS
INDICATING THAT FACEBOOK KNOWS
THE HARM THAT THEY AND INSTAGRAM
CAN DO BUT CHOOSES TO PUT
CLICKS, EYEBALLS, AND AD SALES
AHEAD OF FIXING THE PROBLEM.
>> THE COMPANY'S LEADERSHIP
KNOWS HOW TO MAKE FACEBOOK AND
INSTAGRAM SAFER BUT WON'T MAKE
THE NECESSARY CHANGES BECAUSE
THEY HAVE PUT THEIR ASTRONOMICAL
PROFITS BEFORE PEOPLE.
THE DOCUMENTS I HAVE PROVIDED TO
CONGRESS PROVE THAT FACEBOOK HAS
REPEATEDLY MISLED THE PUBLIC
ABOUT WHAT ITS OWN RESEARCH
REVEALS ABOUT THE SAFETY OF
CHILDREN, THE EFFICACY OF ITS
ARTIFICIAL-INTELLIGENCE SYSTEMS,
AND ITS ROLE IN SPREADING
DIVISIVE AND EXTREME MESSAGES.
>> AS YOU'D IMAGINE, THIS IS NOT
THE COMPANY'S PUBLIC POSITION.
LISTEN TO WHAT CEO MARK
ZUCKERBERG TOLD LAWMAKERS JUST
LAST MARCH.
>> THE RESEARCH THAT WE'VE SEEN
IS THAT USING SOCIAL APPS TO --
TO CONNECT WITH OTHER PEOPLE CAN
HAVE POSITIVE MENTAL-HEALTH
BENEFITS AND WELLBEING BENEFITS.
LIKE HELPING PEOPLE FEEL MORE
CONNECTED AND -- AND LESS
LONELY.
>> MARK ZUCKERBERG TALKING ABOUT
THE RESEARCH THAT HE'S SEEN.
NOW, FRANCES HAUGEN ON RESEARCH
WE DO NOT KNOW WHETHER HE'S
ACTUALLY SEEN BUT HE WAS
CERTAINLY PRIVY TO BECAUSE IT
WAS DONE BY THE COMPANY, ITSELF,
HIS COMPANY.
>> FACEBOOK'S OWN RESEARCH ABOUT
INSTAGRAM CONTAINS QUOTES FROM
KIDS SAYING I FEEL BAD WHEN I
USE INSTAGRAM.
BUT I ALSO FEEL LIKE I CAN'T
STOP.
RIGHT?
I -- I KNOW THAT THE MORE TIME I
SPEND ON THIS, THE WORSE I FEEL.
BUT LIKE, I JUST CAN'T -- LIKE,
THAT THEY WANT THE NEXT CLICK.
THEY WANT THE NEXT LIKE.
>> AND IN GENERAL, SO DO
INSTAGRAM AND FACEBOOK BECAUSE
THAT INCREASES ENGAGEMENT WHICH,
IN TURN, HELPS ADVERTISING
REVENUE.
THAT MUCH IS A SIMPLE FACT ABOUT
THE WAY THAT SOCIAL NETWORKS
OPERATE.
THE FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION IS DOES
FACEBOOK BUILD THEIR ALGORITHM
KNOWING IT HARMS CERTAIN USERS?
FRANCES HAUGEN SAYS THE ANSWER'S
VERY SIMPLY YES.
>> IS FACEBOOK EVER OFFERED
FEATURES THAT IT KNEW HAD A
NEGATIVE EFFECT ON CHILDREN'S
AND TEENS' MENTAL HEALTH?
>> FACEBOOK KNOWS THAT ITS
AMPLIFICATION ALGORITHMS, THINGS
LIKE ENGAGEMENT-BASED RANKING ON
INSTAGRAM, CAN LEAD CHILDREN
FROM VERY INNOCUOUS TOPICS LIKE
HEALTHY RECIPES.
I THINK ALL OF US COULD EAT A
LITTLE MORE HEALTHY.
UM, ALL THE WAY FROM JUST
SOMETHING INNOCENT LIKE HEALTHY
RECIPES TO ANOREXIA-PROMOTING
CONTENT OVER A VERY SHORT PERIOD
OF TIME.
>> TODAY'S HEARING FOCUSED
HEAVILY ON FACEBOOK AND
INSTAGRAM'S IMPACT ON KIDS.
IT ALSO DEALT WITH FACEBOOK'S
REAL IN AMPLIFYING ELECTION
LIES, POLITICAL VIOLENCE, AND
EVERYTHING ELSE SURROUNDING THE
2020 ELECTION AND ATTACK ON THE
CAPITOL.
NOW, BEFORE WE PLAY YOU SOME OF
THAT TESTIMONY, THOUGH, HERE'S
WHAT FACEBOOK'S VICE PRESIDENT
FOR CONTENT POLICY SAID ON CNN
EARLIER TODAY.
>> RESPONSIBILITY FOR JANUARY
6th LIES WITH THOSE WHO BROKE
THE LAW AND THOSE IN POLITICS
AND ELSEWHERE WHO INCITED THEM.
AND THE WORK THAT WE DID, BOTH
BEFORE THE ELECTION AND ALL THE
WAY THROUGH JANUARY 6th.
PARTNERING WITH ACADEMICS AND
RESEARCHERS.
WORKING CLOSELY WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND ELECTORAL
AUTHORITIES TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
THE RISKS WERE.
AND TO PUT SAFETY MEASURES IN
PLACE THAT -- THAT STARTED
BEFORE THE ELECTION, WELL BEFORE
THE ELECTION, AND CONTINUED
THROUGH MARCH.
THAT WAS WORK THAT I AM VERY
PROUD TO HAVE BEEN A PART OF.
I'VE -- I'VE, FRANKLY, NEVER
SEEN, YOU KNOW, SUCH AN EFFORT
TO PREPARE FOR AN ELECTION.
>> NOW, THOSE SAFETY MEASURES
WERE AIMED AT LIMITING THE
SPREAD OF FALSEHOODS,
MISINFORMATION, AND INCITEMENT.
AND AS YOU HEARD MS. HAUGEN SAY
ON THE PROGRAM LAST NIGHT, THEY
DID NOT WORK VERY WELL.
AND ANY CASE, THE SAFEGUARDS
WERE LIFTED IMMEDIATELY AFTER
THE ELECTION AND RESTRICTIONS ON
THE SO-CALLED STOP THE STEAL
MOVEMENT WEREN'T IMPOSED UNTIL
AFTER THE CAPITOL ATTACK.
NOW TODAY, MS. HAUGEN HAD THIS
TO SAY ABOUT WHY IN HER JUDGMENT
THE COMPANY DID NOT MAINTAIN
THOSE SAFEGUARDS LONGER.
>> THE CHOICES THAT WERE
HAPPENING ON THE PLATFORM WERE
REALLY ABOUT HOW REACTIVE AND
TWITCHY WAS THE PLATFORM?
RIGHT?
LIKE, HOW VIRAL WAS THE
PLATFORM?
AND FACEBOOK CHANGED THOSE
SAFETY DEFAULTS IN THE RUN-UP TO
THE ELECTION BECAUSE THEY KNEW
THEY WERE DANGEROUS.
AND BECAUSE THEY WANTED THAT
GROWTH BACK, THEY WANTED THE
ACCELERATION ON THE PLATFORM
BACK AFTER THE ELECTION, THEY --
THEY RETURNED TO THEIR ORIGINAL
DEFAULTS.
AND THE FACT THAT THEY HAD TO --
TO BREAK THE GLASS ON JANUARY
6th AND TURN THEM BACK ON, I
THINK, THAT'S DEEPLY
PROBLEMATIC.
>> SO, DID THE LAWMAKERS
QUESTIONING MS. HAUGEN, THE
COMPANY IN RECENT DAYS, HAS
POINTED TO A RESEARCH PROJECT IT
SET UP WITH AN OUTSIDE PANEL OF
EXPERTS TO STUDY THE PLATFORM'S
EFFECT ON THE ELECTION.
HOWEVER, THE COMPANY'S OWN PRESS
RELEASE ON IT OPENLY SUGGESTS IT
DOESN'T CONSIDER ITSELF BOUND BY
ANY RECOMMENDATIONS THAT SHOULD
COME FROM IT.
AND AS FOR HOW THE COMPANY
TREATS ITS OWN INTERNAL
RESEARCH, JUST LAST WEEK, IT
PUBLISHED TWO OF THE INTERNAL
STUDIES WHICH WERE CITED TODAY
ON THE HARMFUL MENTAL HEALTH
IMPACT INSTAGRAM HAS ON TEEN
GIRLS.
NOTABLY, THOUGH, IT CAME WITH
FACEBOOK'S OWN ADDED ANNOTATIONS
REBUTTING OR REFRAMING SOME OF
THE NEGATIVE POINTS.
NOT THE PICTURE OF A COMPANY
WILLING TO TAKE A HARD LOOK AT
ITSELF, AT LEAST NOT IN PUBLIC.
AS FOR INSIDE CORPORATE WALLS?
WELL, FRANCES HAUGEN SPOKE TO
THAT, AS WELL, TODAY.
>> I THINK IN GENERAL, BUT I'D
LIKE YOU TO JUST CONFIRM FOR ME,
THIS RESEARCH AND THE DOCUMENTS
CONTAINING THAT RESEARCH IS NOT
ONLY FINDINGS AND CONCLUSION,
IT'S ALSO RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
CHANGES?
WHAT I HEAR YOU SAYING IS THAT,
AGAIN AND AGAIN AND AGAIN, THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS WERE JUST
REJECTED OR DISREGARDED,
CORRECT?
>> THERE IS A PATTERN OF
BEHAVIOR THAT I SAW AT FACEBOOK
OF FACEBOOK CHOOSING TO
PRIORITIZE ITS PROFITS OVER
PEOPLE.
AND ANYTIME THAT FACEBOOK FACED
EVEN TINY HITS TO GROWTH, LIKE
.1% OF SESSIONS, 1% OF -- OF
VIEWS -- THAT IT CHOSE ITS
PROFITS OVER SAFETY.
>> JOINING US NOW IS
FORMER-ELECTIONS INTEGRITY HEAD
AT FACEBOOK.
FORMER-CIA OFFICER AND
FORMER-WHITE HOUSE ADVISER.
ALSO, JENNIFER, ASSOCIATE
PROFESSOR OF COMMUNICATIONS AT
SYRACUSE UNIVERSITY WHO STUDIES
THE HARMFUL EFFECTS OF SOCIAL
MEDIA ON TEENS.
YOU HAVE BEEN SPEAKING OUT ABOUT
WHAT YOU SAY ARE THE DANGERS OF
FACEBOOK SINCE YOU LEFT THE
COMPANY.
HOW BIG OF A WATERSHED MOMENT
YOU THINK WAS TODAY, GIVEN THE
FOCUS IS NOW ON THE COMPANY'S
OWN DOCUMENTS?
>> WELL, THANKS FOR HAVING ME
ON, ANDERSON.
I THINK IT IS A HUGE WATERSHED
MOMENT.
BUT ONLY IF WE ACTUALLY DO
SOMETHING WITH THE INFORMATION.
YOU KNOW, EVERYTHING THAT'S IN
THE DOCUMENTS, ESPECIALLY THE
DOCUMENTS THAT WERE TURNED OVER
TO THE S.E.C. WHICH HAVE NOW
BEEN RELEASED, I THINK, ONLY
TODAY PUBLICLY.
THEY JUST DEMONSTRATE THE
INTERNAL KNOWLEDGE OF WHAT
FACEBOOK DOES AND DOESN'T KNOW
ABOUT EXACTLY WHAT'S HAPPENING
ON THEIR PLATFORM.
AND IT CONFIRMS WHAT A LOT OF
RESEARCHERS, ACTIVISTS, FORMER
EMPLOYEES SUCH AS MYSELF HAVE
BEEN SAYING FOR YEARS.
SO AGAIN, IT'S UP TO LAWMAKERS
NOW.
IT'S NOT ABOUT WHETHER FACEBOOK
AND GOOD OR BAD OR DOES MORE
GOOD THAN BAD.
IT'S ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT THERE
ARE SOME PRACTICES THAT HAVE
HARMED DEMOCRACY, HARMED
INDIVIDUALS, AND POTENTIALLY
BROKEN THE LAW.
AND WHAT THE LEADERSHIP KNEW
ABOUT IT.
THIS SHOULD ABSOLUTELY BE A HUGE
WATERSHED MOMENT, AND SHOULD
REALLY MAKE THE PUBLIC
UNDERSTAND THAT AT THIS POINT WE
CAN NO LONGER JUST RELY ON
FACEBOOK'S OWN SELF-SELECTED
DATA POINTS AND THEIR OWN
TALKING POINTS WHEN THEY LIKE
TO --
>> JENNIFER, A LOT OF PEOPLE
MADE THE ANALOGY TO BIG TOBACCO
PURPOSELY MISLEADING THE PUBLIC
ABOUT THE DANGERS OF SMOKING.
AND WHEN THAT WAS REVEALED.
DO YOU THINK THIS IS AS BAD AS
THAT?
>> IT'S VERY DIFFERENT.
OVER TIME, YOU KNOW, IT MAY TAKE
SEVERAL YEARS FOR CANCER TO
MANIFEST.
BUT WHAT WE'RE SEEING ON
INSTAGRAM IS AN IMMINENT THREAT
TO TEENAGERS.
I AM SEEING SELF-HARM.
AND THAT SOUNDS SO ABSTRACT WHEN
THE SENATORS ARE TALKING ABOUT
IT.
BUT WHAT DOES THAT LOOK LIKE?
I'M TALKING ABOUT STARVATION.
THAT IS HOW BAD THE ANOREXIA
PHOTOS ARE UP THERE.
I'M TALKING ABOUT TEENAGERS
CUTTING THEMSELVES.
THIS CONTEXT NEEDS TO BE OUT
THERE SO THAT PARENTS UNDERSTAND
WHAT THIS LOOKS LIKE.
AND IT'S NOT SIMPLY JUST, LIKE,
SMOKING A CIGARETTE.
SURE, THE REGULATION DOWN THE
ROAD, YOU KNOW, MAYBE, WE HAVE
TO MANAGE IT THAT WAY.
BUT I THINK WE NEED THAT CONTEXT
RIGHT NOW.
>> YOU KNOW, AS A FORMER CIA
OFFICER, YOU HAVE SAID IN AN
INTERVIEW THAT FACEBOOK KNOWS
YOU BETTER THAN THE CIA EVER
WILL.
WHICH IS -- I MEAN, IT'S A
FASCINATING THING.
A FASCINATING QUOTE.
UM, YOU SAID FACEBOOK KNOWS MORE
ABOUT YOU THAN YOU KNOW ABOUT
YOURSELF.
THAT IS THE REMARKABLE THING.
AND, YOU KNOW, WRITTEN ABOUT
THIS IN HIS BOOK THAT, YOU KNOW,
WE FORGET ABOUT OURSELVES.
WE FORGET.
MY MIND IS LIKE A SIV.
I FORGET THINGS I DID TEN YEARS
AGO OR LAST WEEK.
FACEBOOK REMEMBERS AND IT'S ALL
THERE.
THEY KNOW MORE.
THEY KNOW ABOUT EVERYBODY WHO IS
A CUSTOMER OF THEIRS.
>> YEAH.
I MEAN, OF COURSE, IT WAS A
LITTLE BIT TONGUE IN CHEEK BUT
IT REALLY IS ACTUALLY TRUE.
AND THIS IS WHAT I THINK PEOPLE
REALLY NEED TO UNDERSTAND.
IT'S NOT ABOUT -- AGAIN, IT'S
NOT ABOUT FACEBOOK PURPOSELY OR
INTENTIONALLY SAYING WE WANT TO
GO HARM TEENAGED GIRLS.
OR WE WANT TO RADICALIZE PEOPLE.
I MEAN, THE MOST SHOCKING
REVELATION TO ME WAS THE WHOLE
IDEA OF HOW ALGORITHMS WERE
RECOMMENDING EXTREMIST GROUPS
WHICH IS THE CORE OF WHAT I USED
TO WORK ON AND WHAT I TALKED
ABOUT.
BUT HOW DO THEY DO THAT?
THEY DO THAT BECAUSE THEY HOOVER
UP ALL OF YOUR DATA AROUND THE
INTERNET, NOT JUST WHEN YOU'RE
USING FACEBOOK.
AND THEY SEGMENT YOU INTO THESE
PROFILES TO SELL YOU --
BASICALLY, THEY'RE NOT SELLING
YOUR DATA BUT THEY ARE SELLING A
PROFILE OF YOU THROUGH TARGETING
TOOLS TO ADVERTISERS.
AND IN ORDER TO DO THAT, THEY
HAVE TO KEEP HOOVERING UP OUR
DATA.
AND SO, THEN THEY START TO INFER
NOT JUST WHO YOU ARE, WHAT PHOTO
YOU POSTED TODAY.
BUT WHAT'S GOING TO REALLY KIND
OF PLAY TO YOUR VULNERABILITIES?
AND WHAT -- WH